[Musique]
Olivier de la Marche, bonsoir.
Bonsoir Sky.
Nous vous recevons ce soir pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Syerview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter Sucinten ? Oh euh
économiste, ancien trader. Euh euh j'ai
fait pas mal de d'émissions sur BFM
pendant un bon moment et puis euh
monsieur Macron est arrivé donc euh
jeu de chaise musical, je suis sorti BFM
et puis euh et puis je j'ai continué,
j'ai vendu mes ma société de gestion en
France.
J'ai remonté une société de gestion en
Suisse, familier office en Suisse à
Genève et puis j'écris une lettre
mensuelle pour Agora. Je
je fais des émissions hebdomadaires pour
RT France euh émission économique et
puis voilà et puis pas pas mal d'autres
choses.
Donc on vous on va parler ce soir
finances, marché financier, politique
monétaire, monnaie, inflation et tout un
tas de choses de ce type de joyeusé.
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire ?
Quelle est votre lecture
du reutage de l'économie après la crise
du Covid-19 ? Est-ce que les pouvoirs
publics
ont une bonne lecture et un bon plan, on
va dire le plan à 30 ans, est-ce que
c'est de la politique symptomatique ?
Est-ce que c'est de la politique qui
consiste à faire de la supportation de
vote avec de l'argent public ? Quelle
est votre lecture ? Alors, ma lecture,
c'est que c'est que le Covid en fait
n'est pas euh n'est pas la la
cause euh de nos problèmes. Le Covid,
c'est un c'est un accélérateur, c'est un
détonateur, c'est un catalyseur
d'une situation qui est là depuis en
fait une bonne dizaine d'années. On
s'est jamais sorti en fait de 2008, on
n'est jamais sorti de ce de cette crise
qui n'a pas été une crise d'ailleurs
comme on le dit la crise du siècle loin
de là. Euh c'était une crise, je dirais
habituelle, un petit peu euh un petit
peu plus forte du fait des subprimes et
et euh et de ce qui s'est euh passé et
surtout la mauvaise gestion de cette
crise.
En fait, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Depuis
2000, on est rentré dans une dans une
économie qui n'est drivée que par la
dette.
Il y a que ça.
Que ça ? Ah
parce qu'il y a que ça parce que il y a
plein de il y a plein de choses qui font
que
décennies après décennies, on ralentit
en terme de croissance. On ralentit
pourquoi ? Bah parce que la démographie
est pas bonne. Euh alors ça a pas été
bon du tout au Japon dans les années 90.
Ça a commencé dans les années 90. Là,
toute l'Europe est touchée. On est, vous
savez que le le taux de remplacement,
c'est 210 par exemple par femme. Euh
aujourd'hui, on est à 1,84
en France, on est à 130 en Grèce, en
Espagne, en Italie, on est en dessous
encore au Japon, on est pareil en
Allemagne. Donc aujourd'hui, vous avez
un vrai problème démographique qui n'est
jamais adressé par les politiques.
jamais vous entendrez un politique en
parler
et qui pourtant est est majeur. C'est
constitutionnel si vous voulez.
C'est-à-dire que vous avez des pays qui
perdent des habitants tous les ans et ça
pèse sur la croissance. Ça fait que
votre croissance
potentielle euh qui est qui était dans
les années 60 de 6 ou 7 % aujourd'hui
elle est entre -1 et + 1. Et donc
évidemment ça va entraîner beaucoup de
choses. Ça va entraîner d'abord des ça
va modifier complètement la manière dont
les gens consomment puisque quelqu'un
qui a c'est pas compliqué hein,
quelqu'un qui a 75 ans consomme pas
comme quelqu'un qui en a 30. Donc a
priori vous avez pas les mêmes choses
qui sont achetées. Il a pas il a pas les
mêmes besoins, il a pas les mêmes
revenus non plus. Et donc ça va
entraîner un certain nombre de choses et
et donc vous avez une croissance
potentielle qui diminue. Et puis pendant
ce temps-là, vous avez des politiques
qui savent très bien, ils sont pas fous
hein, ils savent très bien que
plus ils ont de croissance, plus ça sera
facile de se faire réélir. Et comme
c'est leur seul objectif finalement,
c'est pas c'est pas du tout de
il travaillent pas pour la France ou il
travaille pas. Non, ben enf, je veux
dire, je pense que c'est assez clair
pour tout le monde. Je veux dire, le
seul objectif d'un politique
aujourd'hui, c'est de se faire élire. On
a plus d'hommes d'état. Les hommes
d'état, le dernier c'était c'était celui
qu'on fait d'ailleurs aujourd'hui,
c'était le général de Gaulle.
Depuis, on a des nains, on n pas autre
chose que des nains, des nains qui
essaient de se prendre pour des grands
et malheureusement ça marche pas. Donc
vous avez ça se voit tout de suite
malheureusement et donc leur seul leur
seul leur seul objectif
c'est leur carrière, c'est pas autre
chose. Aujourd'hui, la France, ils s'en
foutent complètement. Et donc euh vous
avez des gens qui ne prévoient rien, qui
ne planifie rien, qui n'essa pas de de
trouver un modèle euh qui qui va
permettre au pays de de de continuer à
vivre, de croître et cetera. Non, ce qui
les intéresse, c'est euh c'est de
poursuivre le modèle du euh de de celui
qui a précédé et puis euh euh de faire
en sorte d'être élu euh la prochaine
fois. Donc
vous avez vous avez ce problème qui est
un problème alors je vous dis d'abord
démographique mais aussi le fait que euh
on a on n' pas eu de depuis longtemps de
choc réellement de de de
progrès technique
au même niveau que ce qu'on a eu dans
les années dans les années 50.
c'est-à-dire l'industrialisation, la
robotisation,
le le bien avant l'électricité et
cetera, le moteur à explosion qui ont
fait que ça a généré des croissances
énormes puisque on remplaçait en fait la
force de l'homme par autre chose et qui
était à ce moment-là potentiellement
illimité. Donc ça a fait cette
croissance forte et puis aujourd'hui ben
je vous dis il faut s'attendre à une
croissance qui va faire entre -1 et + 1
et une croissance entre-1 et + 1
malheureusement c'est c'est bien. Donc
le le Non mais non mais on n'est pas sur
BFM.
Donc donc le le refléchage de
l'économie, les les le gouvernement
français, le l'Europe injecte des
liquidité pour le monde d'après. Est-ce
que vous pensez que réinjecter des
liquidités dans Air France ça peut c'est
bien, c'est pas bien ? C'est bien pour
l'emploi ? Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Non, mais c'est c'est idiot surtout.
C'est-à-dire qu'on a un système, je vous
dis, qui ne fonctionne que sur la dette
depuis des années.
On a un problème là qui est une crise
sanitaire mais qui est, je vous dis, le
juste le catalyseur en fait de ce qui
s'est passé depuis 10 ans.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour sortir de
là ? Bah, on rajoute de la dette. Donc,
sachant que la dette, c'est quoi ? C'est
de l'impôt futur.
C'est de l'investissement à long terme.
Non, c'est pas de l'investissement. Non,
c'est pas de l'investissement. c'est de
c'est de la dette pour essayer de faire
en sorte que on ne on ne voit pas trop
qu'on est en train de couler. Donc on
refait de la dette. Mais la dette,
malheureusement, il y a un moment où ou
un autre où ça se transforme en impôt.
Or, je vous l'avais enfin ce qui est
amusant, c'est que je l'ai annoncé ça
depuis le début en disant attention le
le à chaque fois qu'on vous annonce des
plans en vous disant on va mettre 500
milliards et cetera, c'est de l'impôt
futur. Alors le le le jeune Emmanuel qui
vient à la télévision et qui nous dit
"Ah mais non, mais je montrai jamais les
impôts." Il se fout de vous. Il se fout
de vous. D'ici à la fin de l'année, il
vous annoncera un impôt. C'est c'est sûr
et certain. Il ne peut pas faire
autrement. Alors après, est-ce que ça
sera un impôt européen ? Il dira "Bah
c'est pas moi, c'est c'est l'Europe.
D'accord. OK, super. Enfin bon, tu l'as
cherché quoi.
Ou il vous dira oui mais bon un potô de
solidarité Covid et cetera. Peu importe
la manière dont il va le présenter, peu
importe la la manière dont il
l'appellera, ce qu'il va l'appeler taxe,
est-ce qu'il va l'appeler impôt ?
D'accord. OK. Mais une taxe, c'est quoi
? C'est un impôt hein. Au final, c'est
des gens, la population française qui
font un chèque. Point bas. D'accord.
Alors après, vous pouvez l'appeler, j'ai
eu il y a il y a quelques il y a
quelques temps, j'ai eu un un un invité
sur sur RT et qui me disait "Ah mais
non" qui essayait de m' m'en fumer en me
disant "Ah mais non, un impôt c'est une
taxe, c'est pas la même chose.
Excuse-moi." Enfin bon, à la fin tu
payes. Donc c'est la même chose. Il faut
pas prendre les gens pour des cons
mais non.
Comment s'appelle le ministre de
l'économie ?
Bruno Le maire. Euh Bruno Le maire. Que
dire sur Bruno Le maire ? Bruno le maire
c'est un type qui euh sait pas faire un
pourcentage.
C'est monsieur le ministre. Euh si tu
veux, c'est un type qui sait pas faire
un pourcentage. C'est un type qui quand
il était ministre de l'agriculture
euh on lui demande ce que c'est qu'un
hectare, il est il est pas foutu de le
dire. Enfin, je veux dire, moi je veux
bien que on me dise que
c'est stressant de répondre à une
question quand on est quand on est sous
l'œil des caméras, mais enfin, c'est
quand même leur métier. Euh et
c'est qu'est-ce que vous voulez ? C'est
des c'est des incapables quoi. Et des
gens qui s'entourent incapable, je doute
de leur capacité.
Vous, pour reprendre vos mots, vous
pensez qu'on est en train de couler à
l'heure actuelle ?
Ah mais on est en train de couler, mais
on est pas en train de couler à cause du
Covid. On est en train de couler à cause
de la gestion qu'on a fait du Covid et
surtout on est en train de couler par
rapport à toutes les bêtises qu'on a
fait depuis 2008.
Concrètement, ça veut dire quoi ? Ben
concrètement, c'est que euh on a eu que
qu'une chose euh en tête, c'est euh euh
c'est s'endetter parce que ça permettait
de donner une illusion de croissance.
Vous savez que euh je vous donne un seul
exemple,
entre entre 2008 et 2016, donc pendant 8
ans,
l'Espagne
a rajouté
12,30 de dette.
pour faire 1 € de PIB de plus
et on nous dit "Ouais, l'Espagne est
relancée et cetera." Non, l'Espagne est
pas relancé. L'Espagne est toujours au
fond du trou.
Donc c'est ça que je veux dire, c'est
c'est facile de créer l'illusion, c'est
facile de mettre des milliards sur la
table et cetera. Ce que ce que font tous
les pays aujourd'hui, hein, aussi bien
l'Europe que les États-Unis, c'est
open bar. Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Ah bah surtout pas ça, surtout l'inverse
de ça. C'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui il
il aurait déjà fallu faire
faut faire de l'austérité,
non ? Alors il aurait déjà fallu dès dès
laisser
ce qui devait couler couler.
Alors vous allez me dire "Oui mais ça
aurait créé du chômage épouvantable et
cetera."
Oui, sûrement,
mais on se serait pas euh complètement
lié les mains pour la suite des
événements. Or là, aujourd'hui, on s'est
complètement lié les mains et donc on n'
pas voulu laisser faire la récession. On
n' pas voulu que les boîtes qui devaient
couler coulent. Donc, et notamment les
banques qui nous avaient quand même
mises dedans.
C'est quand même un problème au départ
bancaire. Et qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ? On
les a sauvé mais sans contrepartie.
Et on leur a rien demandé hein. À chaque
fois que euh ils étaient reçus euh euh
au ministère des finances, on leur
disait en gros euh excusez-moi de nous
avoir de vous avoir dérangé.
Et pourquoi ? Bah parce que le banquier
il disait "Bah c'est très simple he si
vous m'emmerdez je coupe les vivres à
l'économie." Mais ça faisait longtemps
qu'il prêtait plus à l'économie. Donc
c'était ridicule cette histoire. Donc
euh
fait,
on les a laissé tomber. Bah ce qu'on
fait c'est que c'est que je pense que
aujourd'hui d'abord on gère complètement
différemment le le la crise sanitaire.
Ça a été ahurissant.
On n pas de masque donc le masque ne
sert à rien. Puis en plus si bête nous
dit que on saura pas le maître.
Mais non, c'est quand même compliqué. On
a des masques.
Bon euh oui, on a des masques
maintenant. Euh mais maintenant c'est
après le confinement et cetera.
Est-ce qu'il fallait confiner tout le
monde ? Est-ce qu'on aurait pas dû
tester tout le monde ? Il y a quand même
des pays qui l'ont fait. Est-ce qu'on
aurait pas dû tester tout le monde et ne
confiner que les personnes à risque ?
Vous ?
C'est une question.
Non, moi je suis pas à risque. Je suis
pas à risque. Les personnes à risque,
c'était quoi ? Depuis le départ, on sait
que ce sont les personnes de plus de 70
ans et cetera.
Pourquoi confiner des des gamins à
l'école ? Pourquoi confiner des jeunes
qui peuvent travailler ? Pourquoi ?
Donc il y a il y a une vraie question.
Pourquoi ? Bah je vous réponds. Pourquoi
? parce qu'on a pas de masque, parce
qu'on a pas de test, parce qu'on est des
des des demeurets, des demeurets. On est
là, normalement, il paraît qu'on est la
5e puissance du monde, 6e puissance du
monde et on n'est pas foutu de de de
faire fabriquer des masques en France.
un truc qui va pas quand même. Et quand
vous discutez un peu avec ceux qui ont à
ce moment-là fait venir des masque et
cetera, c'était c'était surréaliste. On
avait l'État qui était incapable de les
prendre, de les distribuer, de les de
les donner à qui de droit et cetera. Enf
c'est hallucinant la façon dont ça a été
géré. Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Et ben
Jacques a dit "Tu restes chez toi, tout
le monde reste chez soi." C'est c'est
bien quand même quand on regarde la
Suède qui se retrouve débordé parce
qu'ils ont pas pratiqué le confinement.
C'était une bonne idée le confinement.
Et la Corée ?
Et la Corée ils ont testé
Corée 60 millions de personnes.
Ils ont testé et ils ont l'habitude de
D'accord. Ils ont eu combien de morts ?
Moins que nous.
Bah donc il y a un problème ? Non je
sais pas. Et alors là, on est en train
de se vanter, on est en train de taper,
je je lisais le Figaro il y a il y a
quelques il y a quelques jours, on est
en train de taper sur le sur le Brésil
parce qu'ils ont 30000 morts.
D'accord. Ils ont combien de de
personnes dans leur population ? 220
millions. Nous, on est 67 millions, on a
30000 morts aussi.
Ouais. Est-ce que les chiffres
brésiliens sont de même qualité que
est-ce que les chiffres français sont de
bonne qualité ? Hein ? Non, mais on peut
se poser la question. Est-ce que vous
pensez qu'on a pris les morts dans les
épades ? Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on a
pris les morts qui sont morts chez eux ?
Est-ce qu'on leur a fait un test à eux
une fois qu'ils étaient morts ? Non.
Donc bon, sur la fiabilité des chiffres,
on peut repasser, hein. Mais chez tout
le monde, hein. C'est pas c'est pas
uniquement au Brésil, ni aux États-Unis,
ni en France.
Sur la gestion de l'économie, qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire ? C'est moi je vous
donne ma baguette magique tout de suite
et je vous mets président de la France
ou ministre de
ou ou ministre de l'économie. Alors
pourquoi ça va faire mal ?
Bah déjà je dégage tous les tous les
incompétents et il y en a un paquet. Il
y en a un vrai paquet. Enfin je veux
dire aujourd'hui quand vous voyez les
les gens qui entourent le premier
d'entre eux d'incompétent
quand même hallucinant. quand même
hallucinant. Vous avez un Castaner,
un Bruno Lemire, Sibet,
madame Boubé,
hein. Donc déjà, vous dégagez ces
gens-là. Ensuite,
moi je me pose une vraie question
euh sur des sur des
pour mettre qui à la place pour mettre
qui à la place ? des gens compétents,
c'est-à-dire des gens pas forcément qui
ont fait l'ENAT, mais des gens qui ont
monté des boîtes, des gens qui savent ce
que c'est que la vie réelle, pas juste
des crétins qui savent pas compter.
Donc et je pense que la France en est
plein de gens qui sont compétents,
qui sont pas des idiots, des demeurs,
des gens qui se font des shoots de de
vodka euh le soir. Euh
enfin bon, je veux dire, on est on est
là, on enfin on a l'impression quand
même qu'on a touché le fond des gens ces
gens-là. Ces gens-là, enfin,
excusez-moi, mais sur les politiques, il
y a il y a quand même quelque chose à
dire. On est on est face à des gens
qui n'ont pas de colonne vertébrale.
Aucun de ces gars ces gars-là, quand
vous parlez de Bruno Lemire, quand vous
parlez de d'Edouard Philippe, vous
vous rappelez les vidéos qui circulent
d'ailleurs ? C'est c'est c'est fascinant
de ce qu'il disait de Macron avant les
élections.
De ce qu'il disait de Macron avant les
élections. Mais ils étaient en train de
dire "Mais c'est le c'est un minable et
cetera." et ensuite ils deviennent
premier ministre, ils deviennent
ministre de l'économie. C'est ahurissant
quand même. Ces gens-là n'ont pas de
colonne vertébrale.
Ils ont quand même soutenu les les
entreprises. Ils ont permis à des
petites entreprises les entreprises.
Non, ils ont pas soutenu les
entreprises. Ils ont pas soutenu les
entreprises. Aujourd'hui, c'est on est
dans on est rentré dans une espèce de de
soviétisation.
La soviétisation, c'est quoi ? Et
aujourd'hui,
si on continue, mais c'est c'est pas
uniquement un problème français, c'est
aux États-Unis, c'est la même chose. Si
on continue comme ça, toute personne
aujourd'hui recevra son chèque
de la part soit de la banque centrale,
soit de l'État. C'est ça qui est
universel, un revenu universel. Un quoi
? Je sais pas si ça sera un revenu
universel, mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
l'État
garantit tout, rachète tout,
fait de la dette mais sans se préoccuper
de savoir si un jour les gens pourront
rembourser, les sociétés pourront
rembourser. Et en fait, quand vous
faites de la dette, vous appartenez à
qui ? À votre créancier.
D'accord ? C'est à ça, c'est à lui que
vous appartenez.
Et en fait au final si c'est l'État qui
garantit vos dettes, vous appartenez à
qui ? À l'État.
Donc vous êtes en plein régime
soviétique
aujourd'hui. Que ce soit aux États-Unis
ou que ce soit en France, vous avez
l'État qui garantit tout. Vous avez
monsieur Trump qui dit "Je rachèterai
tout,
tout." la banque centrale qui a dit il y
a quelques jours, je rachèterai
absolument tout.
Mais on a tous compris que c'est
donc ça veut dire ça veut dire que vous
êtes en régime soviétique avec des prix
administrés par les banques centrales,
avec des des chèqus qui vont venir de la
banque centrale ou de l'État. Donc vous
êtes en plein régime administré.
S'il faisit pas ça, ça produirait quoi ?
S'il faisait pas ça, vous auriez des
sociétés qui feraient faillites, c'est
clair. Mais au moins, on se laisserait
des moyens d'agir après et c'est ce
qu'on n pas fait d'ailleurs en 2008.
à force enfin
je vais vous donner un exemple c'est
c'est typique ces Renault pour moi. Vous
avez aujourd'hui un pays de 67 millions
d'habitants, la France dans lequel il y
a deux sociétés qui fabriquent des
voitures sur le même créneau.
Voiture pas chère, plutôt bas de gamme
ou milieu de gamme, pas du haut de
gamme, pas mal. Bas de gamme, milieu de
gamme. D'accord. Voiture pas chère,
c'est pas c'est pas là où on fait du
fric, on le sait depuis longtemps.
D'accord. Ces boîtes-là n'ont jamais
gagné d'argent. Renault n'a jamais gagné
d'argent en vendant des voitures. Elle
gagne de l'argent sur le financement de
la voiture. Donc Renault c'est une
banque d'abord et avant tout. C'est pas
un constructeur de voiture, faut le
savoir. OK,
vous êtes là. Renault ne gagne pas
d'argent. Or Nissan ne gagne pas
d'argent depuis des lustres.
Cette société-là,
on va lui prêter de l'argent
avec comme condition soi-disant
que elle rapatrie sa production en
France.
Elle fait déjà pas de marge. Si elle
rapatrie sa production en France, elle
en fera encore moins. On est bien
d'accord. Bon,
donc ça sert à quoi ? Ça veut dire qu'on
va dépenser des milliards
pour entretenir
quelqu'un qui est mort cérébralement.
C'est ça que ça veut dire.
Et au final, qu'est-ce qui va se passer
? Dans quelques années, la boîte
fermera, on mettra tout le monde au
chômage et on aura absolument rien gagné
et rien fait. On aura gagné du temps.
On aura gagné du temps mais ça sert à
rien.
Si si au final au même résultat, ça ne
sert à rien. En revanche, d'accord.
Utiliser les milliards
qu'il faut pour continuer la production.
Utiliser ces milliards là pour former
les gens de Renault
et les reclasser ailleurs. D'accord ?
utilisez qu'une petite partie de ce que
vous allez utiliser là pour continuer la
production pour un former les gens de
les reclasser ailleurs et vous fermez
Renault. Qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?
Bah vous allez vous allez avoir Peugeot
qui va exploser. Il y a un de ces
principaux concurrents qui n'est plus
là. D'accord ? Et Peugeot va à ce
moment-là réengager des gens de Renault.
Et là, vous avez quelque chose qui est
intelligent mais qui n'a jamais été
fait, rassurez-vous, en France parce que
c'est intelligent justement.
Et là, vous avez quelque chose qui tient
la route mais vous ne dépensez pas
du pognon de dingue comme disait
monsieur Macron pour rien. Pour rien,
pour au final dans 3 ou 4 ans ou 5 ans
virer tout le monde et avoir une
entreprise qui ne gagnera pas plus
d'argent. C'estàd que dans 5 ans, elle
continuera à en perdre.
Donc là, si je vous pose la question, si
je vous dis bah c'est peut-être c'est
peut-être une façon de gagner du temps,
de laisser les gens avec un peu
d'argent, de laisser une entreprise avec
un peu d'argent pour gagner du temps.
Vous trouvez pas que le climat social
est déjà délétaire, queil y avait déjà
eu un an de gilet jaune, que il y a un
chômage qui est en train d'exploser ?
C'est justement
justement c'est une façon d'acheter au
lieu d'aller dépenser de l'argent
bêtement. Moi je vous dis utilisons-le
intelligemment. Si vous l'utilisez
intelligemment, bah les gens les gens de
chez Renault pendant leur formation,
vous avez de quoi le payer. C'est pas
intelligent. D'accord. C'est pas
intelligent de maintenir un peu la paix
sociale pour passer une un cap un peu
difficile.
Quoi ? Vous la maintenz la paix sociale
là ? Vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé à
Dijon ? C'est ça qui s'appelle maintenir
la paix sociale. Excusez-moi mais vous
soufflez sur les braises. Donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ? Qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé à Dijon ? à Dijon, vous
avez vous avez des tchetchen qui sont
rentrés en conflit avec euh des
Maghrébains euh teneur de cité et
vendeurs de drogue. En gros, c'est le
c'est le c'est le deal et euh
qui avait euh tapé sur un chetchen. Donc
résultat, il y a 100 chechen qui ont
déboulé.
Donc on est on est aujourd'hui en pleine
libation
de la France. C'est-à-dire que on alors
c'est un moyen évidemment de détourner
l'attention, hein. Je pense que euh
monsieur Macron et monsieur Castaner
étaient ravis de ce qui était en train
de se passer. Euh euh monsieur Castaner
qui est prêt à se mettre à genou devant
tout le monde, il a pas compris que en
partant d'une position où il était en
train de ramper, c'était difficile de se
mettre à genou. Mais mais euh ce ils
sont ravis de ce qui se passe. Mais
aujourd'hui, c'est ça que c'est vers ça
qu'on va. Si on continue comme ça, c'est
la guerre civile demain en France. C'est
ce qui se passe au Liban en France.
C'est-à-dire communauté contre
communauté, les Tchchenes, les
Maghrébains,
les
les Catau, les protestants, les juifs
machin. On aura chacun nos milices puis
on va se taper dessus. C'est ça le but
du jeu. Mais c'est ça, c'est vers ça
qu'on vain. C'est vers ça qu'on va.
Enfin, je veux dire, il y a un truc qui
est qui est quand même très simple. Je
veux dire, le le le aujourd'hui,
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait ? Il faudrait
tout juste envoyer l'armée dans les bons
lieux et calmer le jeu.
Et tous les militaires qu'on a
dire, c'est quand même des images
hallucinantes où on voit des gars se
tramaler avec des kalashnikov en plein
Dijon.
En je veux dire,
vous avez fait votre service militaire.
Oui.
D'accord. Un famas tire en milieu
urbain, ça fait quoi ?
Attends,
l'armée n'est pas faite pour intervenir
en milieu donc on envoie Pino simple
flic.
Non, mais il y a il y a un truc qui va
pas. Enfin, je veux dire, il faut il
faut utiliser les mêmes armes que les
que les gars d'en face, sinon ça va être
ça va être épouvantable. Donc il y a un
moment où il faut quand même euh régler
le problème. Aujourd'hui, on a des
bandes organisées qui sont dans les
banlieux avec des des de la police qui
n'osent pas rentrer. Donc il y a un
moment où il faut régler ce problème,
sinon ça va se finir mal. Il faut
militariser notre police. C'est ça.
Bah il faut il faut ou alors il faut
envoyer les unités d'élite, j'en sais
rien. Je je ce que je veux dire c'est
que aujourd'hui faut pas laisser ça. Et
or aujourd'hui quand vous écoutez le
ministre de l'intérieur, il le laisse
faire. Il le laisse faire. Et c'est et
ça c'est inadmissible. Comme c'est
inadmissible aujourd'hui de laisser des
manifestations euh appelées par des gens
qui ont des casiers judiciaires épaisés
comme le botin de Paris. Il y a un truc
qui va pas. Mais réveillez-vous quoi.
Réveillez-vous.
On a une classe politique qui est en
train de ramper.
OK. Revenons à l'économie. Question
d'internet. Que pensent-il de la
Mais c'est de l'économie.
C'est de l'économie parce que justement
le truc aujourd'hui c'est que
on est dans une impasse, on est dans un
vrai changement de modèle, on est on est
arrivé au bout on est arrivé au bout de
ce système qui ne tient que sur la dette
avec une obsolescence programmée qui
fait que les gens sont obligés de
d'acheter toujours plus, qui n'ont pas
de revenu, donc qui recourent eux-mêmes
à la dette. Et c'est un système qui est
qui est euh vissié. Donc on sait qu'on
va dans le mur, on va y aller. Là, on va
y aller plus vite avec le la
cristallanité.
C'est quoi aller c'est quoi aller dans
le mur ? Ça veut dire quoi
aller dans le mur ? C'est que tout d'un
coup, vous allez vous retrouver
exactement comme au Liban avec des
banques fermées qui vous diront bah vous
pouvez sortir 200 balles par semaine
et estimez-vous heureux pour aller pour
aller manger. C'est ça qui va se passer.
C'est euh c'est une monnaie qui va
s'effondrer parce que à force d'en créer
de de de
trons, on est en train de créer des
trillons.
Un trillon, c'est combien de milliards ?
C'est 1000 milliards. Donc vous êtes en
train de créer des trons. Je sais pas si
les gens se rendent compte. Alors
évidemment, c'est difficile de se rendre
compte de ce que c'est qu'un trion, mais
là on on s'amuse, c'est nos limites. Ça,
je l'avais annoncé et réannoncé qu'au
moment où ça se passerait mal, les
banques centrales, ça serait open bar.
Et c'est open bar, c'est-à-dire que elle
rachète tout et elle rachète tout avec
des billets fraîchement imprimés. Ça ça
veut dire quoi ? Ben ça veut dire que
vous pouvez tenir le système. Vous
pouvez tenir ce système qui est
complètement
idiot
où on a 01 % de la population qui se
fait un fric pas possible parce que tout
le fric qui est créé par la banque
centrale part directement dans la bourse
d'accord mais ne passe pas par la case
économie réelle jamais. D'accord ? Donc
va directement dans la bourse et donc
possesseur d'actifs, il est content
hein, il se fait du fric. En revanche,
les autres eux ils payent, ils payent
parce que ça génère une dette, je vous
ai dit, c'est de l'impôt futur. Donc
vous êtes dans un système qui est
schizophrénique,
totalement déléant. Donc il va falloir à
un moment que ce enfin il va pas falloir
ce système va exploser.
Sauf que je doute vraiment que ce
système explose de lui-même.
C'est-à-dire que tout d'un coup les
investisseurs et les opérateurs de
bourse se réveillent un matin
intelligent en se disant "Mais mais non
mais c'est bien sûr à force de créer de
la monnaie, elle va se casser la
gueule." Donc euh c'est pas de là que ça
viendra et c'est forcément
à mon avis socialement que ça viendra.
C'est-à-dire que on va, je vous je vous
l'ai dit là il y a il y a quelques
minutes, on va pour moi, si on continue
comme ça, on va pour moi vers une guerre
civile. Et si on a une guerre civile, à
ce moment-là, les bourses se casseront
la gueule et les les banques iront au
tapis et cetera. Et donc ça ça va ça va
réellement être un effondrement.
C'est je parle pas d'une petite crisette
hein, je parle d'un effondrement, un
vrai effondrement. Ce qui se passe au
Liban, ce qui s'est passé en Argentine,
ce qui s'est passé au Venezuela, ce qui
s'est passé et cetera. Un vrai
effondrement avec une monnaie qui vaut
plus rien, avec des banques qui ferment,
avec des des des sociétés qui se cassent
la figure avec un taux de chômage
ahurissant. Il est déjà ahurissant mais
il sera encore plus ahurissant et
cetera.
Criminalité,
augmentation de la criminalité, création
de milice, création de mafia. OK. Le
changement de modèle, si vous aviez les
capacités de créer un nouveau modèle,
quelles sont vos pistes ?
Bah, il faut revenir à des choses à des
choses plus
pragmatiques. C'est-à-dire
moi, je je suis convaincu et je l'ai dit
je l'ai dit de multiples fois que il
faut revoir cette espèce de de
au niveau au niveau industriel. D'abord,
première chose, je pense qu'il faut
récupérer notre souveraineté. sortir de
l'euro. Bon, ça c'est des c'est des
choses que qu'on dit depuis longtemps.
On sait que ça ne marche pas, donc il
faut changer de de modèle. Quand quelque
chose ne marche pas, au lieu d'en d'en
mettre plus,
il faut il faut vraiment
le réinventer et donc sortir de l'euro
et récupérer notre souveraineté. Je
pense qu'il faut essayer de viser une
autonomie, même si on sait qu'évidemment
tous les pays ne seront pas autonomes,
mais
il y a des choses qui sont aberrentes.
Vous savez que
sur des des des
blancs de poulet
ou sur des filets
ou sur des filets de cabillot qui sont
pêchés en mer du Nord, vous savez ce qui
se passe ? On les envoie
en avion,
en Chine.
En Chine,
on met des seringues dans ces dans ces
filets pour mettre de l'eau dedans pour
les faire gonfler de l'eau et des
saloperies. He je vous le dis tout de
suite, il y a pas que de la flotte.
Pour les faire gonfler, pour que ça pèse
plus lourd et on les renvoie en France.
Non mais il y a pas un truc qui va pas
là. Il y a pas un truc qui vous choque ?
le filet de cabillot, il vous fait 15000
bornes.
On fait quoi pour la les retraites ?
Donc
alors attendez
déjà vous m'avez dit sur le modèle, il y
a des choses qui sont qui sont comme ça
euh idiotes.
On devrait aujourd'hui réindustrialiser
la France, remettre
des le plus de choses possibles. Alors,
j'ai bien dit le plus de choses
possibles. On remettra pas tout, mais il
faut remettre de l'activité en France.
Il faut pour ça protéger nos frontières.
Euh
il faut il faut pas se tromper,
c'est-à-dire il faut avoir des
dirigeants qui ont comme l'avait fait le
général de Gaulle, une une vision des
choses et pas la vision de leur de leur
prochaine élection à 5 ans. C'est que
dalle. Il faut prévoir les choses et
donc au niveau énergétique et cetera se
poser des vraies questions. Là on va
construire des ventilateur énorme
partout en France alors qu'on sait très
bien qu'il y a des régions dans
lesquelles il y a pas de vent. Alors moi
j'en je viens d'une de la région la
moins venteuse de France, c'est le Jura.
D'accord ? Et ben aujourd'hui, vous avez
les constructeurs d'éoliennes qui vous
disent "Ah c'est pas grave, on fera des
éoliennes de 400 m." Non mais
un moment où il faut arrêter d'être con.
D'accord. 120 milliards, on va coller
là-dedans. C'est monsieur c'est monsieur
Macron qui nous a annoncé ça. 120
milliards. Est-ce que vous pensez pas
que les 120 milliards, on pourrait les
dépenser un peu plus intelligemment que
ça ?
Moteur hydrogène.
H
je sais pas. motor hydrogène ou euh vous
savez qu'il y a des des boîtes qui
travaillent justement sur
le la façon de de de d'enlever la
radioactivité de de des déchets
nucléaires. Bon, une boîte qui par
exemple, je pas je vais pas lui faire de
la pub, mais une boîte qui s'appelle
Europlasma qui a qui a trouvé quelque
chose. Alors maintenant, ils sont pas au
stade industriel. Mais est-ce que est-ce
que ça serait pas intelligent d'aller
chercher dans cette dans cette direction
là plutôt plutôt que d'aller mettre des
ventilateurs qui sont moches et qui
servent à rien et qui nous font une
électricité chère ? Est-ce que ça serait
pas possible ça plutôt que d'aller
dépenser 120 milliards là-dedans ?
Voilà, pour un truc qui sert à rien.
Donc il y a il y a vraiment des il y a
vraiment des choses à regarder sur les
retraites. Bah sur les retraite, c'est
un problème démographique
important.
Mais là là non plus c'est c'est jamais
adressé et c'est jamais réfléchi et on
fait des mesurettes. Alors que je te
mets le l'âge de la retraite à 62 ou à
63 ou à 64. Mais le problème il est pas
là. Le problème, il il est que on a une
démographie qui euh fait que vous vous
aurez dans les années à venir de plus en
plus de vieux.
Euh vous aurez de plus en plus de vieux
et de plus en plus de dépendance.
Euh, on vous dit aujourd'hui qu'il y a
euh les derniers chiffres c'était 1,7 %
le chiffre de dépendance, c'est-à-dire
que vous aviez 1,7 actifs pour
indépendant. D'accord ?
Alors, je vous dis comment ça se
calcule. C'est ça qui est qui est assez
amusant, c'est que on fait ça par
rapport à la classe d'âge.
Donc c'est là que c'est faussé. Je vais
vous expliquer très c'est très
facilement ce que ce que comment on
fait. On fait ça par rapport à la classe
d'âge, c'est-à-dire qu'on va dire bon
ben voilà, il y a euh les gens qui sont
entre 20 et et l'âge de la retraite,
donc 64, on va dire. Entre 20 et 64 ans,
il y a tant de population en France.
Et euh en dessous euh de ces chiffres-là
et au-dessus de ces chiffres là, on
considère que c'est des dépendants, des
gamins qui sont trop jeunes pour bosser
et des gens qui sont trop vieux pour
bosser et donc qui sont à la retraite.
Et on appelle ça les dépendants. Et on
fait le calcul en faisant le rapport
entre ces gens-là et la classe d'âge
2064. Le problème c'est que sur la
classe d'âge 2064,
il y en a combien qui sont au chômage ?
Il y en a combien qui travaille pas ?
Voilà. et que si vous vous amusez à
retraiter ces chiffres,
si vous vous amusez à regarder
réellement quel est le poids de la
dépendance,
mais en en tenant compte du chômage des
gens qui travaillent allez 2 heures par
semaine, donc qui sont des quasi
chômeurs si vous voulez et des gens qui
sont RSA, des gens qui sont complètement
sortis du système et cetera et là vous
tombez sur d'autres chiffres.
Là, vous êtes plus proche de 20,
pas un 70, un 20 30. Et ça, ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire que vous êtes à A1
dans les années 2030
à ta de chômage égal hein avant Covid
hein. J'ai j'ai pas été méchant. Donc
pour pour poser une question des
internautes qui n'est pas une question,
c'est une question qui est provoque
Olivier de la marche et l'escroquerie
intellectuelle permanente. Point.
Commentie-t-on l'analyse Comment
concilie-t-il son analyse de la crise de
2008 où il l' il fallait laisser faire
mais par contre pour la crise Covid,
fallait faire intervenir l'État. En quoi
avoir monté une boîte est-il est-il une
compétence ? Une expérience est-elle une
compétence ?
Alors, je vous ai jamais dit que l'État
devait intervenir
au au moment du Covid.
euh économiquement. D'accord. Donc je
conseillerais à ce à cet internaut
d'écouter avant de cracher, c'est mieux.
Euh ça c'est la première chose. Et la
deuxième chose, en quoi monter une boîte
est une compétence ? Simplement que vous
êtes dans la vie réelle. Moi, je fais
pas de l'économie, je suis pas un
universitaire, d'accord ? Je fais pas de
de l'économie. Pour moi, l'économie
c'est pas un truc que c'est pas des
formules mathématiques qu'on a ou c'est
pas une histoire qu'on apprend si vous
voulez. L'économie, je la pratique tous
les jours. Euh j'ai monté des boîtes euh
qui qui ont plutôt bien marché euh
et je suis prêt à à comparer
mes boîtes et mon patrimoine avec
l'internaute. Je pense qu'on va rigoler.
D'accord. Donc ce genre de réflexion, il
peut se les garder mais c'est habituel
hein sur les sur les réseaux, vous avez
des gens qui on dirait pas leur temps et
non qu'une activité c'est craché sur sur
les autres. C'est pas grave, je ça fait
longtemps que j'ai le cuir un peu tané
et que je m'en fiche complètement.
Autre question, mettre des gens
compétents, faut-il mieux une
technocratie ?
Non, il faut des gens qui sont euh qui
sont euh euh
il faut des gens qui sont pragmatiques,
qui sont dans le réel et qui sont pas
euh euh qui sont pas euh obnubilés par
euh euh par leur carrière. Regardez des
pays euh
Alors, vous allez me dire, j'entends
déjà les commentaires qui vont dire
"Ouais, mais c'est pas pareil" et
cetera. OK.
Moi, j'ai remonté des boîtes en Suisse.
En Suisse, ils ont une démocratie.
Vous interrogez un suisse dans la rue,
vous lui demandez quel est le quel est
le le président à ce moment-là, il en
sait [__] rien. Euh vous avez des gens
qui sont là, qui tournent tous les 3
ans, qui ne font pas carrière, qui sont
pas des politiciens pur politiciens, qui
n'ont jamais fait que autre chose que de
la politique. Et vous avez un système
dans lesquels les gens votent deux à
trois fois par mois et et et qui est une
une vraie démocratie parce que là
aujourd'hui vous pensez que vous êtes en
démocratie parce que vous votez une fois
tous les 5 ans. C'est une blague.
Donc
donc
OK. Prochaine question. La BCE ne
pourrait-elle pas répudier les dettes ?
Alors, répudier les dettes,
ça c'est le
grand crédau de euh de la France
insoumise et autres euh grands
économistes.
Euh répudier les dettes, ça veut dire
quoi ? Ça veut dire que on annule la
dette.
Mais est-ce que vous savez qui détient
la dette ?
Hein ? Non, il y a pas que
non, il y a pas que La dette, elle est
pas détenue par
un riche chinois ou la dette, elle est
pas détenue par Bernard Arnaud ou par
monsieur Boloret. La dette, elle est
détenue par vous tous.
La dette, elle est détenue dans chaque
produit bancaire. C'est de la dette dans
un livret. C'est de la dette dans un
dans une assurance vie. C'est de la
dette
majoritairement de la dette française.
Donc si vous l'annulez, qu'est-ce qui se
passe ?
Vous vous mettez votre votre épargne à
zéro en fait. C'est ça que vous voulez ?
Donc je sais pas si si c'est si vous
pensez que c'est c'est intéressant,
faisons-le. Faisons-le.
Autre question. Que pens que peut-il
nous dire de l'affaire Carlos Gun ?
Je pense que comme beaucoup de
comme beaucoup de de gens à qui on cire
les pompes toute la journée,
ce qui était son cas, euh à un moment il
a il est devenu
complètement mégalo et que il a confondu
le le les finances de Renault avec les
siennes.
Voilà. Et que
et que euh alors évidemment c'est rien
rien n'est étonnant là-dedans. Beaucoup
de beaucoup de d'hommes politiques
français le le l'ont applaudi à demain.
Mais aujourd'hui, ça n'empêche que c'est
un type qui est qui est en fuite
qui qui a monté une espèce de cabale pas
possible pour pour sortir du du Japon.
euh et qui est en train de nous
expliquer que vraiment les Japonais sont
euh sont des des méchants et que il
avait bien raison de de sortir.
Les conditions de détention étaient
quand même hardcore, non ?
Bah c'était des conditions de détention.
Enfin euh
il y a un moment où euh quand on quand
on fait des des des conneries, il est
absolument normal de se retrouver dans
une prison. Ce qui est anormal, c'est le
système dans lequel on a ou tu peux être
homme politique, tu peux tu peux faire
des conneries qui coûtent des milliards
et des milliards.
C'estàd qu'on peut être on doit être
plus bourreaux que les bourreaux.
C'est-à-dire que ceux qui font des
conneries, il faut les mettre à genou
les mains croisées à genou sur des
carrés de sucre. Si je suis votre
raisonnement.
Bah oui. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi est-ce que
enfin excuse-moi mais c'est parce que
euh tu es euh tu es un un dirigeant ou
parce que tu es un politique, il te
faudrait un traitement de faveur ? Non
non, c'est appliqué entendu. Mais que ce
soit un dirigeant politique, il faut que
la dignité humaine reste la même.
Mais oui, mais je veux dire, il avait
pas des des des conditions de détention
pire que d'autres délinquanges qui se
qui qui ont été poursuivis par la la
justice japonaise. Je sais pas est-ce
qu'il avait vraiment des conditions qui
étaient très au-dessus de tout
contrevenant
au Japon. Est-ce que le système carcéral
japonais ne ne rentre pas en
contradiction avec les droits de l'homme
? Bon, c'est un autre détail. Autre
question d'internet. Sur l'ensemble de
2019, Renault a enregistré une perte
nette du groupe de 141 millions d'euros
contre un bénéfice de 3,3 milliards
d'euros en 2018. Question : C'est pas
intelligent de ramener la France pour
pour de ramener en France pour calmer
les gens avec de l'emploi et relancer le
savoir-faire français.
Ramer en France.
Ouais. relocaliser la production en
France.
Mais le je vous ai dit Renault gagne pas
d'argent, c'est Nissan qui gagne de
l'argent mais Renault n'a jamais gagné
d'argent.
Renault en lui-même n'a jamais gagné
d'argent. Donc Renault, si Renault ne
fait pas de marge sur les sur les
voitures Renault euh euh alors qu'il les
fait produire ailleurs qu'en France,
est-ce que vous pensez qu'avec un coût
de production qui va exploser, est-ce
que vous pensez que ils vont gagner plus
d'argent ? Bien sûr que non, ils vont en
gagner moins. Donc s'ils en gagnent
moins, qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire d'entretenir cette boîte
jusqu'à plus soif ? C'est pas
intelligent. Vous
Airfance, vous savez combien de Airfance
tous les 5 ans ça fait fit.
On va mettre du pognon. Mettre du pognon
dans 5 ans, ça refera Fit.
Et le pognon, c'est le pognon de
l'internaute qui pose la question.
D'accord ? Il paye des impôts, donc il
paye deux fois son billet.
Quand il part en vacances, il peut dire
merci à Air France parce que il paye une
fois son billet et puis il le paye une
fois dans les impôts.
Si la situation lui va, moi j'ai pas de
problème.
Vous avez voté quoi aux dernières
élections ?
Pas Macron.
Vous avez voté quoi ?
Je vous dirai pas mais pas Macron. Et je
ne voterai jamais Macron.
Vous avez voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon ? J'en
suis sûr.
Non, j'ai pas voté Mélenchon. J'ai pas
voté Macron. Et je peux vous dire que
Macron, je je vous rappelle quand même
qu'on s'était vu avant l'élection,
d'accord ? J'étais venu euh euh faire
une interview avant les élections et je
vous avais dit vous m'aviez dit alors
Macron et cetera, je vous avais dit bah
écoutez c'est un petit banquier, c'est
même pas un petit banquier, c'est un
petit employé de banque.
Et alors il y a des petits employés de
banque qui travaillent très bien.
Mais petit employé de banque, oui, mais
sauf que on on il a enfilé il a enfilé
un costard beaucoup trop grand pour lui.
Mais comme c'estes prédécesseurs
d'ailleurs vous avez les manches qui
dépassent, vous avez
ils ont enfilé des costards beaucoup
trop grand pour eux. On a fait de ce
type un type remarquablement intelligent
et cetera, le petit mozzard de la
finance et cetera. Enfin, le gars, il se
tapait des grands restos,
il assistait à des discussions entre
grande boîte, mais c'est pas autre chose
un banquier d'affaires. Donc,
excusez-moi, mais c'est c'est c'est
relativement limité. Et quand on voit
les personnes dont il s'est entouré, je
suis pas sûr que ce soit quelqu'un
d'intelligent. Moi, les gens
intelligents, en général, ils
s'entourent de gens intelligents.
Combien combien il gagne Olivier de la
marche ?
Il gagne pas mal d'argent.
C'est quoi pas mal d'argent ?
Il gagne beaucoup d'argent, on va dire.
C'est quoi beaucoup ?
Écoute,
suffisamment pour me faire plein de
plaisir
sympa. Voilà, je vais pas te donner un
chiffre, ça va faire hurler tout le
monde. Je gagne beaucoup d'argent.
Un peu de philanthropie.
H
Je gagne beaucoup d'argent. Je fais ce
que je fais ce que ce qui euh ce qui
m'intéresse. Je le réinjecte dans mes
boîtes. Je fais mais je fais beaucoup
d'argent. Ouais.
Un conseil pour faire beaucoup d'argent,
est-ce que est-ce que c'est sain de
faire beaucoup d'argent ?
Euh un conseil pour faire beaucoup
d'argent, ne pas chercher en à à en
gagner en fait. C'est-à-dire euh
c'est-à-dire faire son boulot
honnêtement
euh euh
avec
une
avec pas pour objectif de gagner de
l'argent mais réellement de bien faire
son boulot. Hier, on a reçu euh le
directeur général de Laagir Carco euh
qui a refusé de donner son salaire parce
queil avait des obligations au sein de
sa boîte. Et certains internautes ont
dit "Les gens qui refusent de dire
combien ils gagnent, c'est que c'est
parce que ils estiment être trop payés
pour ce qu'ils font."
Pas du tout. C'est parce que j'estime
qu'en ce moment où c'est dur pour
énormément de monde,
euh
je n'ai pas à faire le mariol parce que
je gagne de l'argent. L'argent que j'ai
gagné, je l'ai je l'ai durement gagné.
J'ai bossé comme un dératé pendant des
années. Euh j'ai jamais changé de cap,
j'ai jamais
j'ai jamais pris le melon. Euh
je je fais tout ce que je peux pour que
les les choses se passent bien pour les
gens qui me font confiance. Euh je ne je
ne cherche pas euh forcément à en gagner
mais il se trouve que
j'ai gagné beaucoup d'argent. Voilà. Et
donc euh et si les gens sont pas
contents parce que je leur donne pas le
montant pour qu'ils puissent en plus râ
gagne, c'est pas grave. Je m'en fiche
complètement. Voilà. Et pourtant, je
peux vous dire qu'en plus, je pourrais
en gagner 10 fois plus. C'est-à-dire si
je faisais les choses réellement pour
maximiser ce que je gagne, je ferais
payer les conseils que je donne et
cetera et et je le fais pas. Je passe
des heures au téléphone avec des gens
pour les aider sans contrepartie. Et
donc voilà.
Alors question
comment sortir de l'euro et changer de
monnaie ?
Bah aussi simplement, je dirais que vous
y êtes rentré.
Le problème c'est que justement on ne
peut pas en France aborder le sujet.
D'accord ? Dès que vous commencez à
aborder le sujet d'une sortie de l'euro,
vous avez toute une bande d'énergumain
d'européistes qui arrivent en disant
"C'est une religion pas touchée. Vous
allez être excommunié. Vous êtes
d'extrême droite, vous êtes un nazi,
vous êtes et cetera toutes les conneries
qu'on peut entendre
[Applaudissements]
et on peut pas en parler alors que dans
d'autres pays, on peut en parler et puis
je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de gens
qui pourraient aujourd'hui
discuter de ça
posément et chercher une porte de sortie
parce que c'est un peu facile. de dire
vous savez c'est comme le c'est comme le
communisme he si le communisme a pas
marché c'est que il y en avait pas assez
et ben là on nous dit si l'euro marche
pas c'est qu'il y en a pas assez bah non
si l'euro marche pas c'est que c'est un
truc qui ne peut pas fonctionner
qui est mal monté qui est mal pensé qui
ne peut pas fonctionner et si ça peut
pas fonctionner pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas se réunir autour d'une
table et réfléchir à comment défaire
euh ce truc et on le fera pas. On le
fera pas parce que c'est dogmatique,
c'est un c'est une c'est une quasi
religion le le le l'euro. Donc
on ne pourra pas le le déconstruire
intelligemment et en essayant de
contrôler la sortie. Donc ça nous ça
nous pètera la figure à un moment ou à
un autre. On a quand même vu que les les
Italiens euh ont commencé à douter
beaucoup pendant la crise du Covid de
l'Union européenne et de l'euro. Et je
pense que les Italiens finiront par
sortir. Euh quand j'ai commencé à dire
ça il y a il y a il y a 2 ans au moment
des élections italiennes,
tout le monde m'a rayonné. Maintenant,
j'ai l'impression que les gens se
marrent beaucoup moins. Voilà. Donc le
le je pense que réellement cette crise a
prouvé encore une fois que
les les pays au moment de où où ça va
mal, bah c'est chacun pour sa gueule
quoi.
Vous faites référence aux Italiens qui
qui étaient fait référence aux Italiens,
aux Grecs, aux Espagnols, au à tout le
monde. Je veux dire, on a vu les
Allemands et cetera, on a vu notre
président qui nous disait qui nous
expliquait que le virus avait pas de
frontière et qu'il fallait surtout pas
fermer les frontières et puis le
lendemain, vous aviez madame Merkel qui
fermait les frontières de l'Allemagne.
Enfin, je veux dire, on voit bien que
quand il y a un problème, c'est chacun
pour soi. Ce qui est logique d'ailleurs,
chacun pour soi. les pays, ils sont pas
ils sont pas là à demander la permission
de faire quelque chose ou de pas faire
quelque chose à monsieur Macron. Donc
le le l'Europe n'a pas n'a pas de de de
raison d'être et c'est une aberration.
On pourrait très bien avoir depuis
longtemps. Non, pardon,
on n pas de guerre depuis longtemps.
Mais
c'est c'est pas parce que il y a il y a
1 € enfin.
Il y a pas de guerre depuis longtemps.
Il il y a pas de guerre non plus.
euh euh avec d'autres pays qui sont qui
sont pas dans le le l'Union européenne
et qui sont pas dans l'euro. Quel est le
rapport ? C'est c'est le c'est le c'est
le l'absolu
bêtise de de l'Européisme qui vous sort
son son qui vous agite son petit drapeau
européen en disant "C'est grâce à ça
qu'on n pas la guerre." Enfin, c'est une
plaisanterie ou quoi ? On n pas la
guerre parce qu'on a la dissuasion
nucléaire. On n pas la guerre parce que
je pense que on a pris on a pris notre
notre lot de de d'horreur pendant la
dernière et que on n' pas envie de se de
se faire la guerre. Et puis je vous
rappelle quand même que la guerre en en
Serbie c'était c'était quand même sur le
le le continent européen et euh ça n'a
pas empêché. Donc enfin, je veux dire,
tout ça c'est des c'est des c'est des
c'est des bêtises.
Vous pouvez très bien imaginer que vous
ayez des des conventions entre
pays qui vous permettent de faire des
affaires sans être obligé d'avoir la
même monnaie. Les Suisses, les Suisses,
l'économie suisse, elle se porte pas
mal. Non, je sais pas.
Bah, il y a des fils de personnes qui
essayent d'avoir à manger pendant la
crise
à Genève. à Genève, on a vu que
l'économie suisse n'était pas si propre
que ça, que il y avait énormément de
gens qui sont retrouvés au secours
alimentaire. Donc
aux États-Unis aussi. Bon, ils sont pas
dans l'Eure.
Il y a il y a un moment où il faut
arrêter les en dehors de la finance,
qu'est-ce qui se passe en Suisse ?
Ah bah en dehors de de la finance, alors
je vous explique un petit truc
les gens ne connaissent pas, mais la
finance, ça représente 12 % du PIB en
Suisse,
donc ils ont autre chose, non ? Je sais
pas, ils ont euh ça veut dire que il y a
il y a il y a quand même 88 % du PIB,
c'est pas la finance, hein. Donc euh il
se portent pas si mal, vous savez.
Est-ce que vous avez été approché par
des politiques pour vous lancer en
politique ? Absolument tout le temps.
Alors qui
ça va de l'extrême droite à l'extrême
gauche et
en passant par tout le monde et euh et
là avec la même réponse à chaque fois.
Emmanuel Macron vous a pas appelé. H
Emmanuel Macron vous a pas appelé ?
Non non je je pense qu' il a compris que
je l'aimais pas.
Donc non, Emmanuel Macron m'a pas appelé
mais euh mais euh parce que je pense
qu'il est en train de il est en train de
faire couler le pays euh à une vitesse
qu'on a jamais connu.
Voilà, vous allez
c'est pas le seul hein, je veux dire.
Vous allez vous engager aux politiques
ou pas ?
Non.
C'est un nom ou c'est un peut-être ?
Non, c'est Non.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est pas mon rôle. parce que
je veux aujourd'hui et c'est pour ça que
je me je je change de trottoir à chaque
fois que je vois un politique
parce que je veux garder ma parole
libre.
Question question d'Exo7. Pratique-t-il
l'optimisation fiscale ?
Je pratique l'optimisation fiscale.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pratiquer
l'optimisation fiscale ? J'ai mes boîtes
en Suisse. Oui.
Pourquoi en Suisse ?
pour plein de raisons qui sont euh euh
d'abord que il se trouve que j'ai une
j'ai ma maison dans le Jura et que c'est
assez proche euh de Genève euh et que
secondo euh vous avez euh parce que vous
sortez de l'Union européenne
vous n'avez pas toutes les
réglementations de l'Union européenne
qui sont
un monument de bêtises.
Pourquoi ?
parce que ça vouse euh le le l'Union
européenne se mêle de tout. Vous savez
que il se mêlent de la courbure de la
banane et bien en finance il se mêlent
de de choses qui sont euh purement de la
bêtise parce que
sous sous couvert de protéger
l'investisseur
en fait on on on met la tête de
l'investisseur sous l'eau. Vous savez
que vous avez des trucs quand même assez
ahurissants quand vous avez un que ce
soit un fondat ou que vous avez
donc qui respecte les règles
européennes, c'est ça que ça veut dire.
Ou quand vous avez une société de
gestion avec des des portefeuilles de
particuliers,
vous ne pouvez pas par exemple
euh être liquide. C'est-à-dire, vous
dites à un moment, "Bah écoutez, moi je
pense que la bourse ça va se casser la
figure. Donc je préfère rester en
liquidité sur votre portefeuille. Ne pas
avoir d'action, ne pas avoir d'oblidité.
Bah, vous pouvez pas. Vous pouvez pas
parce que à ce moment-là, vous avez les
autorités de tutel qui vous tombent
dessus en vous disant "Monsieur, vous
n'êtes pas payé pour avoir des
liquidités." Bah si, justement, c'est un
acte de gestion d'avoir des liquidités.
Bah là, vous pouvez pas. Vous ne pouvez
pas détenir par exemple de l'or physique
pour un client en tant que gérant
euh en en France. Vous avez pas le
droit.
Mais en Suisse, vous avez le droit.
En revanche, en France, on va vous dire
"Bah non, parce que c'est c'est
dangereux de détenir de leur physique."
Ah bon ? D'accord. Je savais pas. Euh
mais si vous voulez, vous pouvez acheter
un ETF, un ETF Exchange
un ETF, c'est-à-dire un fond, un produit
financier dans lequel il y a pas le
moindre gramme d'or, hein, mais qui va
répliquer les cours de l'or et qui et
sur lequel vous allez prendre le risque
de la banque qui aimait ce produit
financier.
Ça c'est autorisé, mais vous avez pas le
droit d'avoir de l'or physique.
Excusez-moi, où est la logique là-dedans
? Où est la défense de l'actionnaire ?
enfin de pas de l'actionnaire, de
l'investisseur, elle est nulle. Donc et
tout ça c'est les mêmes. Vous avez des
ratios où vous demandez la logique de la
chose.
Vous avez des des décisions comme ça des
autorités de tutelle qui sont des
transmissions
de décisions de de l'Europe qui sont
hallucinantes de bêtises. que je préfère
en effet être en Suisse où j'ai plus de
liberté,
euh où j'ai moins ces ces contraintes
idiotes euh et où en effet on peut
défendre efficacement
le le l'investisseur et l'actionnaire
plutôt que en France. Voilà,
on va repenser sur
et je et et
dernier point, il est vrai que euh je
suis euh je suis heureux de payer des
impôts en Suisse. Voilà, parce que ça
sert au moins à quelque chose. Tandis
que quand je donne de l'argent à
monsieur Macron, j'ai quand même bien
l'impression de [__] mon argent en
l'air.
Pourquoi ?
Bah parce que je suis désolé, je ça fait
ça fait quand même des années que je
paye des impôts
et ça fait des années que je vois pas la
situation s'améliorer.
Ça fait des années que je vois de plus
en plus de pauvres dans la rue.
Alors que je peux vous dire qu'avec ce
que je paye comme impôt, bah je pouvais
entretenir
4 c personnes
en leur donnant un bon salaire
et en les faisant travailler.
Euh
et donc je je vois pas le bout de ça.
C'est-à-dire que si c'est, je vous dis,
pour dépenser des centaines de milliards
dans des gros ventilateurs qui sont
moches et qui servent à rien, c'est
quand même de l'argent perdu. Voilà,
plutôt que de les donner à des gens qui
seraient heureux de vivre avec.
On va on va repartir sur des g des
sujets géopolitiques. La politique de
Trump, sa relance économique, sa façon
de se positionner, c'est bien, c'est pas
bien, vous attendez des résultats, vous
anticipez des résultats ? Il a raison de
le faire, il a pas raison de le faire ?
Trump, il est en campagne électorale, il
sait que au mois de novembre euh il y a
les élections.
Il va être élu ou il va pas être élu ?
Euh bah, si ça s'effondre, non.
Si ça s'effondre,
euh il a aucune chance d'être élu. Si ça
s'effondre pas, euh
il peut être réélu et donc il tiendra
coûte que coûte. Ça veut ça veut dire
qu'on est là aussi, on est en pleine
soviétisation, on est en pleine
japonisation de la banque centrale et
cetera.
À chaque fois que les bourses baisent de
quelques pourcents aux États-Unis, on
les rattrape au vol, soit par un tweet
de de Trump qui vous dit que il a
découvert le vaccin contre la bêtise,
soit par un un une déclaration de de
Pels qui vous dit euh
le le on va tout acheter.
Donc on est dans une dans une on n'est
plus dans des marchés, on est dans dans
des des prix administrés par les banques
centrales qui fixent donc les prix des
des de tout de tout obligations, des
actions, des matières premières
puisqu'ils achètent tout.
Pourquoi ?
Et ils achètent tout bah pourquoi ? Bah
tout simplement pour que le système
tienne puisque ce système ne il y a il y
a il y a il y a quelques années
les banques centrales se sont mises à
faire des trucs qu'elles n'avaient
jamais fait auparavant. Des banques
centrales aujourd'hui ont des actions.
C'est c'est c'est qu'est-ce qui leur est
passé par la tête ? Pourquoi une banque
centrale a des actions ? Quel est le but
du jeu ? Vous avez les banques centrales
aujourd'hui ont des actions. Vous avez
la banque
centrale japonaise
qui a 80 % de tous les actifs boursiers
japonais.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez le l'indice nick.
L'indice nicky si il était représentatif
de l'économie japonaise, il serait même
pas à la moitié du cours actuel.
Même pas.
Mais qu'est-ce que vous voulez tant que
vous avez une banque centrale qui achète
tout et sans aucune limite ? C'est bien
ça qu'il faut se mettre dans la tête.
C'estàd qu'il y a pas de formule
mathématique qui aujourd'hui vous disent
que le bilan de la banque centrale
s'il atteint tel niveau,
la monnaie s'effondre et les choses
s'effondrent.
rien.
Banque centrale,
elle peut imprimer autant qu'elle veut.
Et c'est ce qui se passe. Moi, j'avais
dit enfin je l'ai je l'ai dit, je l'ai
écrit plusieurs fois et cetera. J'ai dit
le jour où il y a un pépin, le jour où
les marchés jouent une récession,
les banques centrales feront alline. Et
c'est ce qu'elles ont fait.
Ça veut dire quoi ? Holine ? ligne, ça
veut dire qu'elle
mettent tout sur la table.
mettre tout sur la table. C'est-à-dire
que s'il faut 1000 milliards pour
redresser les choses, elles mettront
1000 milliards. S'il faut 5000
milliards, elles mettront 5000
milliards. S'il faut 10000 milliards,
elles mettront 10000 milliards. N'en
doutez pas une seule seconde.
Et on l'a vu là récemment,
le bilan de la banque centrale
américaine, il est passé de 3000
3700 milliards et là on a ajouté on a
ajouté 5 ou 6000 milliards en l'espace
de quelques mois.
Donc il n'y a pas de limite.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut se retrouver
demain avec un bilan de la Fed à 20000
milliards, c'est-à-dire 100 % du PIB
sans aucun problème. Et ils le feront.
S'il faut tenir, ils le feront. D'accord
? Parce que sortez dans la rue là et
allez dire à quelqu'un le bilan de la
fête c'est 20000 milliards. Il va vous
regarder, il va vous dire ouais alors
hein, comme disait Chirac, ça m'en
touche une sans faire bouger l'autre
hein. Voilà, il va vous dire bah oui et
alors ? Et c'est ce que vont vous dire
les Américains. Oui et alors ?
Et alors le seul problème si vous voulez
c'estàd qu'ils vont pas se réveiller
tous un matin en disant mais oh là 20000
milliards
ça veut dire que mon mon billet de 100
dollars il vaut que dalle.
Donc c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer. Ce qui va se ce qui risque de se
passer, je vous dis, c'est que c'est
qu'à un moment le le l'économie réelle
et le la bourse soit tellement
déconnectée
et que vous ayez une tellement euh
grosse
différence entre, je vous dis, ces 01 %
des plus riches et le le la classe
moyenne qui a été complètement lessivée
par Au Obama et le reste des des
États-Unis où vous avez quand même faut
bien s'imaginer aujourd'hui vous vous
aviez avant la crise vous aviez 50 % des
Américains qui n'avaient pas 400 dollars
devant eux
qui quand ils avaient un pépin de 400
dollars devait emprunter à un ami.
Donc enfin je sais pas si vous imaginez,
c'est la première économie au monde. On
nous vend un truc, on nous vend une
Ferrari,
sauf que dans la Ferrari, il y a pas une
goutte d'essence.
Donc
c'est là que ça risque de de de péter.
Alors après, il suffit d'un prétexte he
ils sont en plus ils sont tous armés,
hein. Je vous le rappelle quand même aux
États-Unis, hein. Il y a combien de de
millions d'armes qui circulent ? 300
millions. C'est c'est pas ce que tu as
dit à un moment. Euh donc imaginez les
dégâts que ça peut faire.
Donc si je vous entends bien, on est sur
un système vissier avec des incompétents
aux manettes, une population qui est en
train de s'appauvrir,
une économie qui est vraiment précaire.
Ça se termine comment ?
Je vous ai dit,
ça se termine
en émeut, en guerre civile.
C'est pour ça que vous êtes parti dans
le jurin.
Ouais. Entre autres.
On a reçu et
je suis bien mieux. Je peux vous dire le
confinement pour moi ça a pas été un
souci. On a reçu Gal Giro ici qui nous
racontait que il avait quelques copains
de la finance qui se barraient
dans les pays nordiques pour éviter ce
genre de tracas et y compris les tracas
climatiques. Euh
si on va vers une guerre civile, si on
va sur des poches de guerri au sein du
territoire,
votre lecture de la chose, vous allez
faire quoi ? L'État va faire quoi ? Vous
faites quoi vous ?
Bah l'état, l'État va faire quoi ?
L'État, je vous ai dit, il rampent, il
se couche.
Donc l'État, si c'est l'État actuel,
hein, il se couche.
Il se couche et donc ça va faire très
mal.
Il s'est pas couché devant les gilets
jaunes. Les gilets jaunes se sont fait
quand même sacrément.
Il s'est pas couché devant les gilets
jaunes parce que les gilets jaunes au au
départ c'était quoi ? des gens qui euh
qui euh travaillaient et qui arrivaient
pas à s'en sortir.
Donc c'est bien qu'il y a quand même un
souci.
Or, ce souci a été traité, non ?
Donc vous pensez quoi ? Les gilets
jaunes, c'est des gens qui euh qui euh
disaient que ils étaient à découvert le
15 du mois
avec la crise là. Ils vont être à
découvert quand ?
le 15 du mois, ils vont être à découvert
le 2 mois.
Est-ce qu'on a traité le problème ? Non.
Non, on leur a tapé dessus. C'est pas
c'est pas une résolution du problème.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des gilets
jaunes ?
Moi ce que je pense des des gilets
jaunes, c'est que alors après il y a il
y a le gilet jaune des des débuts et
puis et puis il y a la il y a il y a la
suite. Euh c'est un un mouvement qui
était euh
qui était au départ quand ils étaient
sur les ronds-points qui étaient tout à
fait,
je vous dis des des gens qui qui bossent
et qui n'arrivent pas à s'en sortir.
malgré le malgré le travail qu'ils font.
Donc
c'est catastrophique pour pour la la 6e
puissance au monde. Et puis après, je
dirais ça a été ça a été récupéré par
des des mouvements politiques, ça a été
récupéré par l'extrême gauche. Euh ça a
été
copieusement
excité. par les black box ça et puis ça
a été
les black block
oui ça a été surtout
ça a été surtout encore une fois
on on a laissé pourrir la situation et
même on a on a bien excité les choses
pour que
ça ça parte en ça parte en vrille et je
pense que ça a arrangé le gouvernement
à un moment de de comme ça pendant ce
temps-là il pouvait
passer toutes les toutes les bêtises
qu'il a qu'il a faites et puis et puis
là tout d'un coup le le la crise
sanitaire.
Alors je pense que le fait de confiner
c'est aussi c'est aussi en partie par
peur de du pouvoir qui se disait comme
ça ils seront chez eux et puis ça sera
plus facile à à contrôler. Euh il il ça
leur permet de passer un certain nombre
de lois qui sont des lois purement euh
antidémocratique, hein. Les les euh les
le les logiciels euh Stop Covid et
compagnie
euh qui vous permettent de de fliquer la
population. On va très probablement euh
vous expliquer bientôt que le liquide
c'est pas bien parce que ça ça ça permet
le le la communication du virus et on
supprimera le liquide enfin ou en tout
cas ils essaieront de supprimer le
liquide parce que c'est quand même
vachement plus facile de vous fliquer
quand vous vous êtes obligé de dépenser
avec une carte bleue et cetera ou avec
votre téléphone. Enfin, on va vers une
société qui est euh qui est euh purement
la négation de la démocratie, hein. Euh
on vous ça permet de passer des lois euh
comme la loi euh Avia et cetera. Euh
tout ça, c'est euh c'est du c'est du du
de la restriction des libertés sous
prétexte de vous faire peur. Alors,
avant vous faisait peur avec le
terrorisme, maintenant on vous fait peur
avec le virus et ça permet de passer un
certain nombre de lois qui vous privent
de vos libertés.
Et puis euh euh
et puis voilà. Et puis maintenant qu'il
y a des confinements, on s'aperçoit que
en en quelques jours, on on enflamme
la France sur des sur des sujets
qui nous concernent pas. Enfin, je veux
dire, on a on a un type qui s'est fait
tuer aux États-Unis.
D'accord. OK. Mais enfin, c'est un fait
d'hiver aux États-Unis. Fit d'hiver, il
y en a beaucoup quand même.
Non, c'est un fait d'hiver aux
États-Unis. D'accord. Au départ, c'est
un fait d'hiver aux États-Unis. Euh, on
a on a on a importé ce fait d'hivers.
Pourquoi ? Des des des Enfin, je veux
dire
il y a Mike Tyson qui a bien résumé le
truc, qui a dit "Mais euh est-ce que
vous pensez que euh si on faisait une
émeute à chaque fois qu'un noir tue un
blanc ? aux États-Unis, il y aura des
émotes tous les jours.
Je dire il y a un moment pourquoi
importer ce ce fait d'hiver ? C'est un
fait d'hiver, même si c'est
oui, c'est affreux. Enfin bon, c'est un
fait d'hiver américain. Pourquoi le
coller et l'importer ici
ici par une famille de par une famille
de gens
qui sont tous des éprits de justice ?
copieux, hein. Donc, excusez-moi, enfin
c'est c'est la la place de ces gens-là,
c'est en prison. C'est pas autre c'est
pas autre part. Et que aux États-Unis
règlent le problème. Si le flic a a fait
une une bêtise, bah le gars, il va en
tôle. Et alors ? Et point. Quel est le
problème ?
Il y a pas de violence policière en
France.
Mais si, bien sûr qu'il y a des
violences policières. Mais il y a des
violences policières parce que racisme
dans la police
parce que les parce que les les Mais
enfin
arrêtons il y a des cons partout un
il a des racistes partout il y a des
cons partout il y a des violents partout
c'est pas que chez le partout et un
uniforme.
Pardon ?
Un raciste qui a un flingue et un
uniforme ça pose problème ou pas ? Et
oui, ça pose problème, mais le le si
c'est pas c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut
étendre ça à toute la population. On
essaie on essaie de nous dire que les
Français sont tous racistes.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? Parce qu'il y a un
type qui s'est fait tuer aux États-Unis.
Euh quel est le rapport ? Excusez-moi.
Enfin,
je comprends pas. Il un truc qui
m'échappe.
Voilà. Et vous avez une famille de
délinquants, mais plus que de
délinquants,
qui se fait tout d'un coup le
porte-drapeau de l'antiracisme en en
France. Ça veut dire quoi ?
Et on les laisse faire. Et vous avez
Castaner qui nous dit "Ah ben ouais, je
me mettrai volontiers à genou."
Mais non, mais c'est un gag. C'est un
vrai gag.
Il fallait pas manifester contre les les
violences policières
là la la manifestation appelée par les
traoré.
Non mais manifestations sont interdites
mais monsieur Castaner peut l'autoriser
parce que c'est sous le coup de
l'émotion. Quelle émotion ?
Alors enfin c'est c'est la porte ouverte
à tout non ? Ou
moi sous le coup d'émotion j'ai flingué
un mec hier
donc ça passe.
Crime passionnel.
Non mais enfin bon il y a un moment où
il faut arrêter.
Non croyez pas.
Tout ça c'est de la blague.
Tout ça c'est de la blague. Excusez-moi.
Enfin positionnement les après vous avez
tous les bobos d'artistes et de machins
qui se qui vivent même pas ici qui qui
sont venus rajouter de l'huile sur le
feu. Mais enfin on vit où ? On vit où ?
L'État est où ? Il pas d'état.
Il y a des mecs à genou.
Ça peut aller que mal quand vous avez de
quand vous avez une telle démission au
sommet de l'État, ça ne peut aller que
mal.
Faudrait faire quoi à votre avis ?
Avoir des couilles, ça serait pas mal.
Ou des overs.
Enfin, je veux dire, faire leur boulot,
on leur demande pas d'être des génies.
On leur demande de faire leur boulot. Et
faire leur boulot, c'est pas
s'agenouiller.
C'est faire respecter la loi. C'est
et c'est à un moment dire stop et pas
souffler souffler sur le feu sur les
braises. C'est c'est c'est ridicule ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire. Et et et
ils vont nous emmener dans le mur. Je
vous ai dit enfin euh euh on va avoir
une une libation de de euh de la France.
On on y court, on y court avec des avec
des
Ça ça se couille les chechen qui se
balade avec des cages. Non mais je je
Oui, ça m'a secoué parce que je trouve
ça inadmissible
et on voit quand même des des des
discours, le discours de de du maire de
Dijon, de Repsam, le discours de d'un de
ses d'un de ses assistants mais qui
cherche à justifier le truc enfin mais
c'est pas justifiable
qui cherche à vous dire que c'est le le
l'équipe de vendeurs de drogue de de de
Maghrébains qui ont attaqué le TCchen
qui finalement ont défendu Dijon. C'est
une blague ou quoi ?
Donc non non,
si on laisse faire ça, c'est la fin,
c'est le Liban. C'est le Liban. Vous
allez avoir des miles, je vous dis, de
telle et telle communauté qui vont se
tirer dessus à qui mieux mieux. L'État
l'État est coincé. Il se retrouve. Mais
non, mais l'État est pas coincé. Si
l'État fait son boulot, je vous dis euh
c'est euh euh les euh je vais être je
vais être vulgaire, mais les fouteurs de
merde, vous les mais vous les mettez en
tôle, quoi. On
s'arrête, on s'arrête 2 secondes. Les
tetchen la plupart qui sont en France
pour la plupart euh sont rompus au
manimement des armes de guerre.
C'est bien pour ça que je vous disais,
c'est des militaires qu'il faut envoyer.
C'est pas Pino simple flic qui qui tire
trois cartouches par an. Non, ça marche
pas. Si on lui donne autre chose qu'un
LBD, il pourra peut-être faire autre
chose. Non, c'est bon, une blague qui
passe pas. E euh on va arriver à la fin
de notre interview. Je vais repasser sur
les questions.
Impeccable. Pendant pendant ce temps-là,
euh
je suis en train de lire une propos OK.
Alors, beaucoup de critiques, une
proposition concrète à part avoir des
couilles et virer les incompétences,
s'il vous plaît.
Mais déjà, ce sera pas mal. Ensuite
ensuite mais non mais après
économiquement il y a plein de choses à
faire si vous voulez. Moi je je je suis
pas certain que le je vous ai dit un
sortir de l'euro c'est déjà une
proposition. le fait de ne pas soutenir
euh bêtement des sociétés qui de toute
façon n'ont jamais gagné d'argent et le
faire autrement, c'est-à-dire former les
gens, les reclasser, les mettre ailleurs
et euh et et gérer intelligemment les
choses, çaen est une autre de
proposition. La la une autre
proposition, mais ça c'est une
proposition que je fais depuis très très
longtemps, depuis 2008, c'était de
séparer, de refaire un glace tigelac, de
séparer réellement les activités
purement bancaires et les activités de
marché et de laisser tomber évidemment
les les banques de marché quand elles se
cassait la figure. Et ben elle se
cassait la figure. Mais au moins ça ne
touchait pas vos dépôts. Ce qui sera
fait là aujourd'hui. Rendez-vous compte
que aujourd'hui quand vous êtes dans une
assurance vie ou quand vous êtes dans
une banque, vous êtes en risque. Vous
êtes en risque. On vous piquera votre
argent. C'est une certitude. D'accord ?
J'ai pas la date mais on vous piquera
votre argent. On fera ce qu'on appelle
un bellin, c'est-à-dire ce qui a été
fait par exemple à Chypre, on vous
piquera votre argent ou ce qui a été
fait au Liban, les banques fermeront et
à ce moment-là, on vous piquera votre
argent. Donc ça c'est des propositions
qui sont concrètes. Euh euh arrêtez de
de de faire uniquement de la dette. Euh
si vous voulez faire des choses
écologiques, les réfléchir, ne pas faire
des des je vous ai dit des ventilateurs,
mais faire autre chose. Ne pas se
précipiter dans le tout électrique pour
les voitures parce que personne
aujourd'hui ne sait comment euh euh
ne sait comment recycler les batteries.
Euh euh les batteries, c'est des métaux
euh rares et c'est des terres rares et
euh et aujourd'hui on sait que c'est
absolument dégueulasse et que c'est en
plus quelque ressource qui est finie
exactement comme le pétrole. Donc euh et
là si si euh vous avez euh si vous avez
suivi le pétrole qui vaut euh entre 25
et 30 dollars le baril, je vous rappelle
parce que personne évidemment ne ne pas
tout le monde parle de baril mais
personne ne sait exactement ce que
c'est. Un baril, c'est 159 L de pétrole,
d'accord ? 159 L, ça vaut 30 balles.
Faites la division, ça vaut que dalle.
C'est une énergie qui vaut que dalle
avec une petite bouteille de gibin,
d'accord ? Mais remplie d'essence.
Vous savez que vous faites vous faites
avancer une voiture sur plusieurs
centaines de mètres, voire de
kilomètres. Donc ça veut dire quoi ? Ça
veut dire que c'est une énergie très peu
chère. Est-ce que vous pensez que la
chute du prix du pétrole là qui est
récemment, est-ce que vous pensez que
cette chute des prix du pétrole va
forcer les grandes boîtes à aller
chercher une énergie alternative alors
qu'ils ont un truc qui vaut rien ?
Donc bien sûr que non.
Donc il y a il y a plein de choses à
faire aujourd'hui qui sont vraiment des
choses écologiques. Arrêter avec ces ces
aberrations de de de
d'obsolescence programmée, euh arrêter
le plastique,
faire des bouteilles consignées comme on
faisait avant quand on était gamin. Moi
je aujourd'hui je je
vis près d'une d'une exploitation
viticole. Euh il y a il y a des années,
on récupérait les bouteilles de vin que
les gens rapportaient et cetera. On
récupérait les bouteilles, on les
nettoyait et on remettait du vin dedans.
D'accord ? C'était pas une consigne mais
on remettait du vin dedans. Aujourd'hui,
ça coûte moins cher
de racheter des bouteilles à chaque
fois.
Donc les bouteilles, elles partent à la
casse. Est-ce que vous savez, il y a un
truc quand même qui est effarant,
on vous oblige
à euh faire le tri de vos déchets.
D'accord ? Vous avez tous et on a tous
une poubelle
bleue, une poubelle grise et cetera. Et
donc on met on fait le tri de nos
déchets. Est-ce que vous savez ce qui
est recyclé réellement
sur le le tri que vous faites ? Il y a à
peine 7 % qui est recyclé.
Il y a à peine 7 % qui est recyclé. Tout
le reste, ça part en Inde, ça part en
Chine, ça part en Afrique et c'est des
poubelles à ciel ouvert, immenses et
cetera dans lequel il y a il y a il y a
tous vos déchets que vous avez gentiment
euh euh trié. Est-ce que c'est pas
aberrant ? Est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
faire autrement ? Donc voilà, ça c'est
des choses tout à fait concrètes. Alors
c'est c'est
ça commence par une bonne critique parce
que si vous savez pas exactement où on
en est, c'est difficile de de d'avoir
des solutions. Mais là aujourd'hui, il y
a des solutions concrètes et je vous dis
la première solution c'est de virer tous
les incompétents.
OK.
Sera déjà pas mal. Deux choses, deux
questions. Alors, c'est pas une question
mais on va on va la lire quand même.
Vous parlez d'avoir des couilles mais
vous ne les avez pas pour dire qui vous
avez voté.
J'en ai marre de ces questions à la con.
Voilà.
Autre question
vos solution c'est laisser couler les
entreprises, former les gens qui se
retrouvent au chômage sortir de l'euro
et
pourquoi les former pour qu'il se
retrouve au chômage justement pour
éviter qu'il se retrouve au chômage.
Oui, c'est former ceux qui arrivent au
chômage les former les former les
chômeurs, excusez-moi.
Sortir de l'euro et récup
non avant qu'il soit chômeur,
sortir de l'euro et récupérer la
souveraineté, tout ça sur fond de guerre
communautaire. La question c'est
préparez-vous le terrain pour Marion
Maréchal depuis Genève ?
Tu
as pas d'autres questions cons comme ça
? Enfin non mais franchement question
franchement
ça veut dire quoi ? Est-ce que je
prépare le le lit de de Marion Maréchal
Le Pen ? Non, je la connais pas et je
m'en fous. Voilà. Donc c'est pas c'est
parce que dès que dès que vous donnez
votre sentiment objectif,
vous êtes un vous êtes un un quelqu'un
d'extrême droite. Pourquoi ? Il faut il
faut juste ramper pour pour être bien
pour vous. C'est ça votre truc ? Bah je
rerrai pas.
Autre question de Filou 88. Un avis sur
les cryptonnaies.
On en arrive toujours au même point.
C'est assez amusant.
Euh bah toujours le même. J'ai pas
changé d'avis. Voilà. Euh si vous avez
on était ici il y a quoi ? Il y a 2 ans,
hein. Il y a 2 ans, j'avais j'avais dit
ce que je pensais de des cryptos. Je
pense que euh je pense que la blockchain
est quelque chose d'intéressant,
qu'elle va sur sûrement
euh pouvoir être développé pour faire
pour faire certaines choses qui
sont intéressantes. Je ne sais pas
lesquelles, vous allez voir parce que
c'est pas ma spécialité.
En revanche, pour moi, si vous voulez,
la crypto en tant que crypto
ne sert à rien, sauf à être un un
support de trading comme pourrait l'être
beaucoup de choses autres et n'est en
cas une solution à vos problèmes. Là
donc je l'ai dit x à chaque fois de
toute façon il y a toute une communauté
qui euh
qui va me tomber dessus. J'en ai
l'habitude euh en me disant que je suis
vieux, que j'ai rien compris, que et
cetera. Non, ça n'est pas une monnaie.
Euh
maintenant
que vous alliez dessus, que vous jouiez
dessus, que vous gagnez beaucoup
d'argent dessus, très bien. Je suis ravi
pour vous. Euh moi, je mettrai pas 1 €
dessus. Euh
voilà. Après, mais mais je je veux pas
empêcher les gens de le de le faire,
mais pour moi, si vous voulez, c'est
exactement
le troupeau de mouton qui pour fuir le
loup se jette dans le ravin. Voilà, donc
le la crypto c'est le ravin. Et pour
fuir quoi ? Pour fuir les l'excès et la
la bêtise surhumaine des banques
centrales qui sont en train d'imprimer.
Donc on se dit "Oh, notre argent vaut
plus rien." Donc on va vers autre chose
qui vaut pas plus d'ailleurs. Mais euh
résultat, vous êtes mort à la fin.
Donnez-moi le nom de deux Français que
vous respectez ou que vous admirez ou
que et français vivant.
Français vivant que je respecte et que
j'admire.
terrasse.
[Rires]
Euh oui,
on lui passe le bonjour.
On lui passe le bonjour. Non, je vais
vous dire les les Français vivants que
je respecte et que et que je je
j'admire, c'est euh
c'est c'est une amie qui est
viticultrice à côté de chez moi. C'est
voilà, c'est des gens qui qui qui font
bien leur boulot, qui font de belles
choses et et qui me paraissent
un million de fois plus intéressants que
ces gens qui sont totalement vides et
qui nous qui nous dirigent. Voilà. Donc
il y a plein de gens intéressants, il y
a plein de il y a plein de gens qui sont
qui sont vraiment intelligents, même
s'ils ont pas même s'ils sont pas
enarques, même s'ils sont pas
Normaliens, même s'ils sont pas qui sont
qui ont une une intelligence terrienne
que je respecte beaucoup plus que des
crétins surdiplômés.
Est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est dans
l'air de la défiance dans ou dans l'aire
du scepticisme ?
Euh on est dans l'air de la de la de la
défiance plus que du scepticisme. De la
défiance parce que parce que parce que
on a toujours été et depuis cela depuis
longtemps, on a toujours été trahi par
les gens qui étaient censés nous
protéger et nous guider.
Donc plus de la défiance. Oui,
si vous deviez dîner avec un président
de d'une nation,
euh si je vous propose Erdogan, Donald
Trump, Vladimir Poutine, Emmanuel
Macron, Angela Merkel,
euh
tout le monde va dire que comme je bosse
sur RT, je suis un j'ai ma carte du FSB,
donc je vous le dis, je l'ai pas
demandé, je l'ai pas eu. Ils me l'ont
pas proposé. Euh euh
pas la capacité de vous la proposer.
Non, mais euh
Poutine
Poutine si vous voulez parce que euh
je préfère le joueur d'échec au joueur
de bingo.
Voilà, je pense que c'est plus
intéressant.
Pense que c'est plus intéressant. Après,
c'est qui le joueur de Bingo ?
C'est les autres. C'est monsieur Macron,
je pense que c'est à sa portée le bingo.
Euh, monsieur Trump aussi. Je pense que
c'est c'est le le probablement le plus
intéressant. Euh c'est
Poutine.
Erdogan, c'est un c'est un mafieux,
pas plus, pas moins qu'un mafieux. Donc,
j'ai pas très envie. Euh
après
euh je dirais quand même je pense que ça
doit être plus drôle de dîner avec avec
monsieur Trump qu'avec monsieur Macron
et qu'avec Angela Merkel. Ouais.
Vous gagnez combien sur RT ?
Je gagne un petit peu d'argent parce que
je vous rappelle que je vis dans le
Jura, que jusqu'au confinement, je
venais toutes les semaines, que je me
prenais un hôtel, que je venais par en
train pour faire l'émission. Donc
vous êtes pas défrayé,
hein ? Si si, je suis je suis défrayé de
de du montant qui me paye. C'est-à-dire
que je gagne 1000 1250 balles par
émission. Voilà.
moins tout ce que je vous ai dit. Donc
euh c'est pas c'est pas des montants
énormes.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Et avant ça, il
nous faudrait trois livres.
Euh
un conseil pour les jeunes générations.
un d'avoir l'esprit critique
euh de se méfier quand un politique leur
dit quelque chose
euh
et trois trois de malheureusement je
pense que ça va être extrêmement
difficile pour eux donc
de s'armer
et pas forcément c'est pas une forcément
une question de de je vous ai dit
d'étude
mais euh euh d'essayer de
d'essayer de réfléchir plutôt que
d'avoir une une espèce de culture
totalement artificielle et qui sert
souvent pas à grand-chose.
Avant les trois livres, j'en profite
pour vous poser une question. Quelles
sont ces ouvert quelle est votre
ouverture préférée aux échecs ?
Je alors je vais vous dire je je
j'ai appris et je jouais aux échecs
quand j'étais gamin et depuis bien
longtemps
je ne je ne joue plus aux échecs. Donc
je suis incapable de vous dire ce qu'il
je ne suis pas un joueur d'échec et je
ne je ne je suis incapable de vous dire
quelle ouverture est préférable.
Voilà.
Euh, on n pas parlé d'écologie.
H si un peu avec les ventilateurs.
Vous vous changez vos habitudes de
consommation pour vous adapter à
l'écologie. Qu'est-ce que vous faites
concrètement ?
Oh, concrètement concrètement j'ai un
potager. Concrètement euh je préfère
de beaucoup acheter local, acheter bio,
acheter voilà. Et donc quand je peux le
faire, je fais en sorte de
pas
de pas forcément
acheter des des choses hors saison. euh
et cetera. Donc voilà. Bon, après
je me force pas non plus, hein. Euh je
trouve ça meilleur. Donc
trois bouquins.
Trois bouquins.
Euh
ben écoutez euh celui que je vais écrire
avec Pierre Sabatier cet été.
Et puis euh et puis euh vous lisez
quoi en ce moment ?
Vous lisez quoi en ce moment ?
En ce moment j'ai lis rien là. Je suis
en en pause parce que je travaille
beaucoup donc j'ai pas le temps.
Euh je suis en train de faire beaucoup
de choses et malheureusement j'ai pas le
temps de lire. Euh qu'est-ce que j'avais
lu de sympathique ? J'ai lu,
j'ai relu il y a pas très longtemps un
livre de Charles Gav euh
des
c'était le titre c'était des lions menés
par des Annes ou je sais plus quoi. Euh
et puis euh et puis et puis et puis
euh qu'est-ce que j'ai lu d'autre
récemment ?
Pas grand-chose,
pas grand-chose mise à part
des tonnes de
bouquin.
Alors, j'ai lu un bouquin mais je le je
souhaite pas à mon pire ennemi parce que
je me le suis avalé très vite. C'était
c'était toute une étude
de de
la des Nations- Unies sur la démographie
pour écrire mon papier sur la
démographie. Donc je peux vous dire que
je m'en suis avalé
3 à 400 pages et que c'est franchement
pas drôle. Voilà.
Olivier de la marche, merci.
Merci à vous.
[Musique]